les clients les plus fidèles auront été
là jusqu'à la toute fin
bisous viau pizzeria une institution à
toronto a fermé ses portes dimanche
après 63 ans d'existence
victime collatérale de la coved 19 très
laid une décision qui arrache le coeur
pierrât et et or est poli et c sont
isolées comme la majeure partie de leur
clientèle
le chiffre d'affaires de la pizzeria
avait chuté de 70% en raison de la coved
19 la fermeture devenait inévitable
eric et cindy ridicules et stupides à la
pizzeria fondée par ettore et ses frères
en 1957 avait résisté à la crise du
strass et attirer des invités de marque
au fil des ans dont le premier ministre
trudeau
à 81 ans et aurait lui se rappellera
surtout des amitiés créées au vaisseau
viau old friends are made in dossier des
amis en dernier qui venait gâter leurs
petits enfants avec une pointe de pizza
pauvres ici l'expérience cet
établissement de haute gastronomie est
situé tout près de bay street ainsi que
du domicile des maple leafs et des
raptors le restaurant ouvert depuis
quatre mois à peine doit déjà se
réinventer le défi est de nous démarquer
et de développer une clientèle dans
cette mer de restaurants qui font de la
livraison et des mets à emporter
explique-t-il boeuf bourguignon
tourtière québécoise et pièces de viande
de luxe l'établissement joue sa survie
en faisant le pari d'offrir du luxe pour
emporter
à la microbrasserie et pop japonais
godspeed les commandes proviennent de
partout en ontario
la crise de la coved 19 a forcé le
commerce à offrir la livraison à
domicile c'était sur ma liste de
priorités depuis de peyregoux donc là on
n'a pas le choix donc on en a mis a
remis en marche notre magasin aldi les
cinq employés restants dont le chef de
cuisine accompli toutes les tâches
la majorité des revenus provenaient des
mets japonais préparés sur place ainsi
que de la vente de bière aux autres
établissements de toronto il a donc
fallu s'adapter
enfin c'est une expérience et une
expérience culinaire experts comme une
usine de production ce que ce que je
veux pas être mais pour le peu de choix
la subvention salariale est prêt sans
intérêt dans le cadre du fonds fédéral
d'urgence pour les entreprises l'aide
gouvernementale donne un coup de pouce
les changements des habitudes de
consommation encore plus on dirait que
on voit trop sûr si tu veux les jeunes
les gens y vont ils vont vraiment
supporter de local le slogan du commerce
est fabriqué avec difficulté et amour
ça n'aura jamais été aussi vrai que
maintenant ici philippe leblanc radio
canada toronto